[Musique]
la semaine a débuté avec la célébration
de la journée de l'europe une date qui
marque la signature de la déclaration
schuman texte pionnier de la
construction européenne rédigée dans les
yvelines à bazoches sur guyonne lieu où
a résidé l'un des pères fondateurs jean
monnet l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et le cnrs ont
renouvelé leur partenariat pour 50 plus
un accord qui permet de développer la
recherche dans de nombreux domaines et
d'attirer des chercheurs d'excellence
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rend hommage à
simone veil pour marquer le cinquième
anniversaire de sa mort la bibliothèque
du canal a décidé de mettre à l'honneur
cette figure emblématique du combat des
femmes à travers une exposition jusqu'au
18 juin coup d'envoi du bac c'est la
première fois depuis la réforme que les
lycéens plancher sur leur nouvelle
épreuve de spécialité à cette occasion
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer s'est rendu dans un
lycée à marly-le-roi pour aller à la
rencontre des élèves et des enseignants
la biennale d'architecturé du paysage
fait son grand retour à versailles
initié par la région ile-de-france cette
seconde édition est consacrée aux liens
entre la terre et les villes avec un
fort accent sur le développement durable